Ukraine says its defenses
managed to shoot down 29
out of 30 missiles
fired in an overnight
countrywide bombardment.
Here you see one
of those interceptor missiles
this is one
that was targeting the capital of Kiev.
Ukraine's military says one civilian
was killed by fragments of a missile
that was shot down
and two other civilians were injured.
CNN's Sam
Kiley is in southeastern Ukraine for us.
So, Sam,
Russia has claimed that it struck
a Ukrainian arms depot.
Is there any truth to that?
There may be.
We wouldn't be allowed to report it
if it was we. I front can be honest.
We simply don't know.
There have been Russian
air strikes
that have been successful in attacking
logistics nodes
of the Ukrainian
armed forces in the past.
But the Ukrainians insist that
only one of those 30 missiles
fired at its territory got through.
One person was killed in Odessa,
we believe, by the descent of wreckage.
So there is one missile unaccounted for
and we don't know where it went.
But this is part of the Ukrainian effort
to try to make sure that the Russians
do not manage to adjust their fire
and targeting.
Based on the information
they may get from us,
from social network bloggers and others
more widely.
I think, Brianna,
the really key issue here
is the relentless
pace of these air attacks.
We're now seeing them on a scale
that a few months ago we'd see
perhaps weekly, perhaps every ten days.
Now we're seeing them
on a very significant scale
nearly every night,
particularly large numbers
of cruise missiles being fired some 30
last night.
Fewer of this short haired, low level
or low,
low tech drones manufactured in Iran,
but all clearly focused on
trying to overwhelm, obviously,
the air defenses here
and soak up
the ability of the Ukrainians
to defend themselves.
I think
ahead of what the Ukrainians are saying
is a coming summer offensive.
In short,
the Russians want to be able
to safely get into the air
and support their troops when it comes to
an increase in the pace and
violence of the ground war, which,
of course, is continuing,
particularly around the city of Bachelet.
All right.
Sam Kiley
live for us in southeastern Ukraine.
Thank you for the latest in on the war.
We appreciate it, Jim.
For the first time,
we are learning
that Ukraine
has fired the long range storm shadow
missile successfully at Russian targets.
The UK provided
the cruise missile ahead of Ukraine's
highly anticipated counter-offensive.
A short time ago,
I spoke with the UK
secretary of State
for Defense, Ben Wallace.
And here is our conversation beginning
with those missiles
Well, look how
we just
got informed by the Ukrainians
that they had successfully used them.
I presume by that it has been successful.
I don't know the full details
We obviously, like
the other allies,
are not involved in such detailed
use of our gifting.
We we just make sure that they are gifted
what they request
and we do it within the boundaries
of whether it's obviously in accordance
to helping Ukraine defend itself
and making
sure that it's a calibrated response.
All I can confirm is,
is that it has been used successfully.
That is the information
I received from the Ukrainians,
and I'm pleased that it is helping them
to defend their country.
Looking ahead, this is,
of course, central.
This is one of many weapons systems
considered central
to the highly anticipated
Ukrainian counteroffensive.
In your view.
Does Ukraine
have all it needs
to order
the start of that offensive when they
are ready?
It definitely has
a significant part of what it needs to
to start an offensive
when the time is just right
by their military commanders
and their political leaders.
And you know that the West,
the United States, United Kingdom
and the rest of many of the powers
in Europe have donated
significant amounts.
We've also a company
that was training to make sure
that they are not only basically trained
but also trained to a more advanced level
to deliver some combined arms.
But, you know,
it's easy
for me
to say thousands of miles away
and anywhere else,
you know, everyone should get on with it.
It's not going to be me
that fixing a bayonet
and walking towards a machine gun
and all the difficult tasks
that Ukrainian leaders
are going to have to task.
But I think
I think we are over a year
on, we're in a position
where the Ukrainians
now have in many areas
some advantages over the Russians
and should they seek to
to try and push them back.
You know,
it is clear
they could be able to do that.
But, of course, you know, we'll see.
War is unpredictable.
We when I was serving
in the armed forces,
we used to say no plan survives
contact with the enemy
and we'll see how it goes.
But Storm Shadow
just like the US
drifting hi,
Miles are very, very important
components of allowing Ukraine
to be successful.
If Ukraine chooses to attempt
to take back
Russian territory
in Crimea,
as well as the eastern
parts of the country.
Would the UK support that
if that's their decision to do so?
It's their sovereign soil.
It's a bit
like you asking me if
the US were choosing to take back
parts of Texas
from an enemy that had invaded it.
You know,
you wouldn't
you wouldn't take anyone else from abroad
telling you what you can
and can't take back.
It is it is Ukrainian soil.
It is their sovereign territory.
It's been invaded
they've lost thousands of lives
as a result of that invasion.
And I think ultimately
it'll be Ukraine's decision
under international law.
They have every right to do that.
In accordance of self-defense.
Britain isn't
going to stand in the way of that.
But I think, you know,
we are a long way from that
where we're in a position
where at the moment
the Russians have lost
consider amounts of land
that they took in February last year,
but they still hold on
to significant amounts.
And it will be for Ukraine to decide
what access,
what advance they make and
and where they do it within that country.
As you know,
US officials have publicly warned China
from supplying arms to Russia
for the war in Ukraine.
Has chided China to date
heeded those warnings.
Is there any evidence
that it has supplied lethal military aid?
Well,
I think one of the most
disappointing things for Russia
throughout this process is that
China has hardly been
a full throated
supporter of Russia we've seen in the UN.
China has consistently abstained
it hasn't voted in favor.
In fact,
we saw, I think recently a vote
in another UN body
where effectively
China went against Russia.
And we haven't seen to date
any more than words and a bit of support
that could change.
And I think that's why the United States
issued that warning.
That could change.
But for now, I think Russia
Russia has demonstrated to China
that this war was a bad choice by Russia.
I think China recognizes
that it also has a friendship
with Ukraine
that this is bad
for business, it's bad
for instability, is bad for China.
And therefore,
I don't think it's in China's
interest to fuel
a disastrous war with more weapons.
So I think for now,
the US
and most disappointed by
China will be Russia.
For all of the talk,
Russia's friend
hasn't come to the rescue.
And secondly,
Ukraine are making advances.
The global community
has a role to play here
in saying to Putin, these
things are unacceptable,
and that includes China and India.
We did see that publicly.
If you remember
last year,
China and India did say to Putin,
it would be unacceptable.
I haven't seen anything change
from that posture.
And this is why the Indian community
is so important in messaging
to President Putin
that his decision was wrong.
He's broken international law.
He should stop his invasion.
He should reverse it.
And he doesn't have any friends.
I mean, that's the key.
You know,
you don't find China
a full throated supporter.
You don't find,
you know,
even his Central Asian traditional allies
and are criticizing him for it.
He's pretty much on his own.
And I think when everyone else has left
the party, he should reconsider.
I know the U.K.
and a number of others
have expressed
concern about allies
who might pressure
Ukraine at some point to
to give up territory
in exchange for a cease fire.
And I personally have heard
from Western leaders,
particularly in the eastern
part of Europe, concerned
that there are some in Europe
who might apply that pressure to Ukraine.
Are you aware of any such pressure?
And what would the UK's response be if
if Zelinsky or others were told
hinted in some way?
Listen, you got to make a deal.
When I've worked
with the Ukrainians on
and off for nearly the last seven years,
First of all, the Ukrainians are tough
and pressure will just fall off.
The main sadness
of any one nation rang out and said,
we think you should do something
and they don't want to do it.
They won't be pressurized.
And that's one of the lessons
of the last
18 months of the invasion
is that everyone has underestimated
that determination.
But, you know, I was in Berlin yesterday.
I saw a very strong resolve
from the German government
to stand by Ukraine
to make sure
that they can defend themselves
and defend
not only the same freedoms
that you and I enjoy, but also that
they should be allowed to enjoy.
You know,
if you look at the statements
from President Macron
to President Zelensky's visit,
that's getting tougher towards Russia.
Not not a watering down
the direction of travel
of the international community
is actually stronger than it's ever been.
The type of Western systems being gifted
is another sign of a strong determination
to make sure Russia gets the message that
we ain't going anywhere.
Understood.
Well, Mr.
Minister, thanks
so much for taking the time.
We appreciate the conversation
Thank you.
Thank you, Jim.
The UK is also joining the US in warning
about the rising threat from China
in Asia. And Boris.
I asked the defense minister there
if President Biden's cutting short
his trip to Asia would send any sort of
signal of weakness to China.
And he said in his view,
no, that actions
speak louder
than words out there, particularly
the joint US Australian
UK Defense Treaty.